all right valentine's day for some
couples is a day full of love for others
maybe
new to a relationship or maybe you're
dealing with some financial issues
it can be a tough day uh worrying about
you know trying to make it that perfect
gift could be a little pricey
kirsten joyce joining us now in the
studio to tell us how to feel
comfortable
in your gift giving decisions right
denise okay right everybody's different
now the cdc is advising everyone to
celebrate valentine's day this sunday
safely this year that leaves much more
room to create that
romantic personalized experience at home
above all experts say it shouldn't be
about breaking the bank you don't want
to do that to show your valentine that
you care
still that doesn't mean that people
won't spend to say i love you
the retail association of nevada
estimates that more than one million
nevadans will spend about 210 million
this weekend
let's break that down for you on par for
overall spending
the individual spending is you know down
about 16 percent compared to last year
amounts to about 164 dollars on average
while candy flowers and cards are still
the top gift many are choosing less
expensive options for their gift giving
opting more for personal experiences as
they celebrate at home
some are skipping the gift giving all
together still want to give a gift
and you're on a budget consider many
other options
instead of an expensive dinner out opt
for a home cooked meal or picnic
in or in your backyard or the local park
you could also consider romantic movie
night in or
hey recreate your first date there's an
idea folks
above all relationship experts say
especially with all the stresses of the
pandemic it's important to be aware of
the pressure that can come with gift
giving just be
transparent with your partner and find
your own special way to celebrate
because of course
it's the thought that counts denise 100
all right so we asked on twitter do you
plan to buy your partner gift on the
special day well here it is
36 said yep i'm going to do that 64
said nope not this year brian i picture
people recreating the first date like
we're going to sports bar and taking
that swill beer out of the picture
wait a second i thought we were going to
a steakhouse if you're not getting gifts
you can still celebrate safely check
this out on our website
we have an absurd amount of information
here about different things you can do
on valentine's day
from spa days outdoor adventures i'm
still going folks there's something for
every couple
and it's good reading material there's a
lot here for you to do
so if you're still thinking of ideas
eight news now dot com
has got a ton of